the lens of the eye is mainly composed
of water and proteins as we age these
proteins may begin to clump together and
cloud the lens this clouding is called a
cataract cataract surgery is the removal
of the affected lens from the eye and
the insertion of an artificial lens
before your surgery you will be given
eyedrops to dilate your pupil and the
area around your eye will be washed and
cleansed in many cases you will have a
local anesthetic injected around or
behind your eye you may also be offered
a sedative to help you relax
most cataract surgeries lasts less than
one hour
the most common method used for removing
cataracts is phacoemulsification in this
procedure the surgeon looks through an
operating microscope and makes three
small incisions less than one inch long
in or near the cornea an opening is made
through the capsule of the lens and an
ultrasound probe is used to break the
cloudy lens into tiny fragments these
fragments are vacuumed out through the
incisions then an artificial intraocular
lens is inserted intraocular lenses made
of plastic silicone or acrylic compounds
have no moving parts and last for the
remainder of a person's life because the
incisions are so small stitches are
generally not necessary vision often
improves notably immediately after
surgery another method for removing
cataracts is called the extra capsular
technique in this procedure the incision
made near the cornea is large enough to
remove the cataract in one piece again
an artificial lens is inserted to
replace the natural lens recovery from
this type of cataract surgery is usually
slower
because the incision is larger this
procedure does require stitches
however the stitches rarely need to be
removed
after the operation a patch will usually
be placed over your eye and you will be
observed for a short time to be sure
there are no problems such as bleeding
cataract surgery is performed on an
outpatient basis and most patients go
home the same day
since exposure to bright light may
initially be uncomfortable you should
not plan on driving immediately
following the procedure you will need to
make arrangements beforehand for someone
to take you home